Title: Inside Politics With John King - Trump
YT vpx
Channel: 1 - CNN
some new CNN reporting on a witness whose
testimony would be an important building block
in any classified documents case against Donald
Trump.
A key former white house federal official
toll prosecutors trump knew the classification
process and followed it all the times in office.
This is the latest indication that prosecutors
are seeking evidence suggesting trump understood
the process for declassifying documents.
That could undercut the claims that he automatically
declassified everything.
He took with him to mar-a-lago.
Breaking this reporting and joining the conversation
is Zach Cohen, Paula Reid and shan Wu are
back with us let's talk about why it's so
important.
This official who served in both trump and
the Biden administrations, a careerist flr
with the class few indication process, has
spoken to prosecutors about what Donald
[12:29:43 PM]
prosecutors about what Donald Trump knew,
what Donald Trump was told, while he was in
the white house about the process he understood
the rules.
Plus spoke don mcgahn, big players, smart
people, close people to Donald Trump, they
all knew the process and talked to trump about
it as well.
So what trump says publicly contradicts what
you have learned here.
>> Exactly.
This is a career official.
It's somebody who advised the trump and Obama
administrations on the classification process.
It's somebody with direct knowledge of how
those two administrations followed the process
and even cited specific examples about times
that the trump administration followed the
correct process.
So it's really interesting to hear what this
official was asked by prosecutors in both
different investigations.
In the trump probe, prosecutors were really
aggressively focused on anything that had
to do with firsthand interactions with trump,
especially about conversations related to
the declassification process.
We have seen that play out in
[12:30:43 PM]
We have seen that play out in the times of
this interview.
We have seen official gos in and testify before
the grand jury about the declassification
process and about their conversations with
trump.
Compared to the Biden interview, it was very
different.
This official went in and it was about the
mechanics of these boxes.
How did they get packed, who packed them and
how did they make their way to Delaware.
Very different areas of focus.
Trump trying to get a sense of his mind set,
and Biden, they want to hear more about logistics.
>> Correct if I'm wrong, trump oes seems to
be more serious.
The Biden thing is a mistake.
It was something bad and wrong happened.
But the context, the scope of the trump investigation.
>> The Biden interview did not match the intensity
of the trump interview at all.
He's really characterized them as different
tones.
>> Circle back for more details in a minute.
The case you're trying to build against trump,
we focus all the time former chief of staff
is a grand jury witness, former spokesman,
but if it you're
[12:31:44 PM]
spokesman, but if it you're building a case,
sometimes it's the less glamorous witness
who is can do the nuts and bolts.
He knew the rules.
He was reminded of the rules.
>> Absolutely.
And that's what they have been doing.
They are building that kind of foundation
as to his mind settle.
And the point is you can tell so much not
only from the intensity, but the kinds of
questions.
If you're focusing on mind set, there's personal
exposure here.
If you're focusing on factual questions who
are packed the boxes, you're looking all the
is there a problem with the way this stuff
gets transmitted and preserved, not did somebody
commit a crime.
>> We showed the officials.
These are not nobodies.
These are senior people, two of them are lawyers.
Nothing approaching that trump had that standing
order that I could snap.
Nothing approached that.
I can't imagine anyone that worked at the
white house after me would have shrugged their
shoulders and allowed that to go
[12:32:48 PM]
shoulders and allowed that to go forward.
Kelly making the point that we understood
the rules ask we were not casual about them.
Therefore, the process should have been followed.
>> Have you ever heard of the declassification
order?
They have never heard it.
Clearly, they have never seen it, it likely
doesn't exist.
It really undercuts so many of the public
explanations and public defenses that the
trump team has put forth.
He's trying to draw this false equivalency
between the trump documents and the one for
president Biden and the one that has been
closed into pence.
We know from our reporting, even though Biden
and trump are facing the special counsel investigation
swoo the possible mishandling of documents,
those are different in terms of volume.
Dozens of documents versus over 100.
Also the conduct.
Cooperation.
Possible obstruction.
The types of questions prosecutors are asking,
they are just asking about boxes and packing.
[12:33:48 PM]
packing.
The trump lawyers probably wish those were
the questions they were asking about that
investigation.
And it's clear they believe the trump is in
the court of public opinion.
He didn't know the process or have to follow
it.
It's significant because it shows not only
our reporting, but this is the testimony that
they are getting in both cases from an expert.
>> And the expert' testimony helps them about
what was happening.
We know the witness who had eyes on so much
of what trump did.
The former adviser, and a trump loyalist.
Based on what the expert says and the significance
of those witnesses, connect the dots.
>> We have seen the special counsel in the
trump investigation really sort of follow
the adviser in the interview as a road map
for the types of evidence they have been working
to secure in the time since.
They have been pushing to get these records
from the national archives that include communications
about the
[12:34:48 PM]
communications about the declsification process,
which wh did he cls if I.
We know they brought in several senior trump
officials, including Robert o'brien, who told
the grand jury that we had conversations with
trump specifically, directly, and we told
him and made clear there was a process for
declassifying things.
You can't wish it to be true.
The grand jury is hearing the testimony that
this former official laid out as important
months before.
>> Critical reporting in the